digamos que vas a un restaurante y por
curiosidad quieres ver cuáles son las
edades de todos los presentes así que
las escribes todas ellas digamos en una
hoja y resulta ser que estas son las
edades de todos los que se encuentran en
el restaurante en ese momento y además
de todo te interesa presentar la
información así que no se quieres ver
por ejemplo cómo están distribuidas
estas edades a lo mejor te interesa
responder
si hay más jóvenes o más niños o más
ancianos o quizás hay más adultos no
sabemos verdad así que de solo ver los
números no da mucha información verdad
solo son son un montón de números así
que la pregunta es cómo le podríamos
hacer y una forma es poner las edades
digamos en distintas cubetas o
acomodadas en cubetas digamos para
pensar cuántas personas hay en cada
cubeta aunque entonces vamos a hacer un
ejemplo este ejemplo del restaurante
digamos que vamos a escribir algunas
vamos a vamos a construir cubetas o
categorías que a mí me gusta más poner
que son
muy bien entonces tenemos nuestras
cubetas y ahí vamos a ir arrojando el
número de personas que se encuentran en
cada una de esas cubetas o categorías
muy bien entonces quizás la primera
categoría que valdría la pena poner es
la edad de 0 a 9 años verdad también
podríamos poner de 10 a 19 años de 20 a
29 años de 30 a 39 años de 40 a 49 años
50 a 59 años y yo creo que si ponemos de
60 a 69 años con eso hasta verdad no
ninguno que tenga 70 muy bien entonces
ahora vamos a ir acomodando o vaciando
en estas cubetas cuántas personas tienen
entre 0 y 9 años muy bien entonces aquí
tenemos 1 2 3
cinco y seis personas son seis personas
en total que tienen entre 0 y 9 años
vamos a ver cuántas personas tienen
entre 10 y 19 años muy bien así que aquí
tenemos una dos tres personas tenemos
exactamente tres personas y yo creo que
tú ya estás viendo de qué va la cosa
verdad ya podemos ver cuántas personas
hay entre que tienen entre 20 y 29 años
verdad aquí tenemos 1 2 3 4 5 verdad
tenemos 55 personas muy bien vamos a ver
entre 30 y 39 años entre 30 y 39 años
tenemos una
creo que solo tenemos una verdad solo
hay una persona ahora veamos entre 40 y
49 años muy bien
entre 40 y 49 años tenemos una persona
dos personas muy bien tenemos dos
personas ya casi acabamos ahora entre 50
y 59 años tenemos aquí dos personas
verdad está y está tenemos dos personas
y finalmente entre 60 y 69 años tenemos
solo una persona muy bien entonces ya
hemos vaciado toda la información
digamos en estas cubetas y es una forma
de pensar cómo están distribuidas las
edades verdad ahora lo que nos falta es
pensar cómo visualizar toda esta
información y para poder lograrlo vamos
a construir algo que se le conoce como
histograma muy bien vamos a hacer un
programa de toda esta información ok
entonces vamos a tomar todos los datos
que ya están en estas categorías o en
estas cubetas y vamos a graficar
vamos a graficar cuántas personas hay en
cada categoría o en cada en cada cubeta
muy bien entonces vamos a poner digamos
dos ejes aquí tenemos el 1er
ok y vamos a poner otro eje muy bien
entonces en esta digamos primera etapa
vamos a poner que la gente que tiene
entre 0 y 9 años muy bien y si nos damos
cuenta lo más hay seis entonces vamos a
poner
1 2 3 4 5 y 6 muy bien aquí corresponde
al 6 aquí al 5 4 3 2 1 muy bien entonces
cómo vamos a graficar esto vamos a poner
justamente con digamos como una especie
de rectángulo aunque más o menos como
una especie de rectángulo que
corresponde a las 6 personas que tienen
edades entre 0 y 9 años muy bien vamos a
ver cómo le haríamos para las personas
que tienen entre 10 y 19 años muy bien
aquí tenemos sólo tres personas entonces
tenemos solo tres personas y hacemos
nuestra barrita de tres personas verdad
son tres de altura que tienen entre 10 y
19 años entonces yo creo que tú ya
puedes ir haciendo el resto vamos a
seguir haciéndolo los que tienen entre
20 y 29 años verdad son
es más o menos va por aquí el azul el
asunto
más o menos se debe ver así
y aquí tenemos nuestra barra de 20 a 29
años muy bien hay bastantes ahora de
entre 30 y 39 años tenemos solo una
verdad entonces digamos por aquí tenemos
30 a 39 años
y entonces aquí tenemos nuestra barra
rosa muy bien y seguimos con un 40 49
años que y sólo tenemos dos muy bien
entonces tenemos solo
de 40 a 49 años aquí tenemos solo dos
personas y de hecho si se dan cuenta me
pase un poquito vamos a vamos a corregir
esto
ok sólo para que se vea agradable y
tenemos otras dos personas entre 50 y 59
años verdad de 50 a 59 años tenemos sólo
dos personas ponemos nuestra barra y
finalmente tenemos una persona que lo
ponemos con azul entre 60 y 69 años que
quizás ya es un abuelo el que fue a
llevar algún niño
y entre 60 y 69 años entonces qué es lo
que hemos construido bueno a final de
cuentas lo que hicimos fue asignar los
datos en distintas categorías de interés
o lo que yo le dije digamos cubetas
verdad y luego gráfica mos todos estos
resultados en lo que conocemos como un
historia que es como este diagrama de
barras o de rectángulos verdad así que
en realidad parece ser que es un
restaurante que a lo mejor da juguetes o
tiene juegos para que los niños estén
entreteniendo sea verdad o que es
bastante familiar porque si se dan
cuenta el histograma nos muestra que hay
muchos niños hay muchos muchas personas
entre 0 y 9 años verdad aunque también
hay algunos digamos que tienen entre 10
y 19 digamos no sea adolescentes ahora
también podemos observar que hay muchos
entre 20 y 29 años a lo mejor son papás
jóvenes que justo llevaron a los niños y
después bueno hay poquitos digamos
adultos
pues poquitos abuelos verdad entonces
esta es una forma de visualizar todos
estos datos y es bastante útil verdad
porque uno a lo mejor podría pensar en
graficar cada edad con puntos como lo
hacíamos en las gráficas de puntos pero
por ejemplo si consideramos las personas
que tienen un año pues sólo vamos a
tener un punto o las personas que tienen
tres años vamos a tener sólo un punto lo
mismo con las de cuatro etcétera verdad
entonces no nos daría mucha información
nos da mucha más información decir que
hay seis niños digamos entre 0 y 9 años
presentes en el restaurante y por
supuesto esto no sólo es útil con
información para restaurantes verdad en
realidad esto lo puedes hacer para
cualquier colección de datos que
observemos